here's what I don't recommend for 99% of
people watching this you should not have
several YouTube channels one of the
biggest mistakes you can make in the
creater economy is to have several
YouTube channels why Sean because if you
try and Chase two to three rabbits
you'll end up catching none of them many
people ask this question Sean I'm doing
this and I'm doing this and I'm doing
this should those be on three
channels my answer often times is well
by the sounds of it those things are so
different
yes but I'm you're asking the wrong
question in my opinion the better
question is what one thing what one
YouTube channel what one
business should I focus on right
now that has the highest
likelihood of helping me reach My
ultimate personal
financial and career goals I want to
invite you guys to our YouTube 1K
challenge you can join this challenge
for free as we show you how to grow your
first 1,000 subscribers and make your
first $1,000 on YouTube we've had
countless people join us during this 1K
challenge who are now at 1,000
subscribers and past 1,000 subscribers
making money on YouTube and you could be
the next person if you just go to 21k
challenge.com you can sign up for the
very next challenge and we can't wait to
see you guys there so even though I
might have helped you clarify oh yeah
those are three different niches so you
should divide up the content into three
different buckets we're at the wrong
place in the
conversation unless of course your goal
is not to unless you don't have any
career goals financial goals and your
goal is to just create content and
organize it well if your goal is to
create content and organize it well then
you really want to put this over here
and put this over here and put this over
here I'm trying to help you step back
and say where is it you want this to go
what's the brand what's the vision
what's the mission what's the what's the
mission what's the
business and which vehicle
AKA which one YouTube channel has the
highest likelihood of getting you there
then it would be your discipline to not
do the other channels but to focus
follow one course until successful it's
worth writing down Focus f o c s follow
one course until successful the acronym
to get
hyperfocused and avoid doing multiple
channels regardless if that's the best
way to segment the content I'm asking
all of us how could you actually do
less not
more it is of my opinion with many scars
to show over my last 20 years doing
video and 16 years doing
YouTube that the majority of
creators are slowing down
their arrival time at their destination
because of too much busyness too much
distraction and too much wasted time
you're going to get there faster by
doing
less it's a hard less to get clear on
but you got to get clear on your goals
clear on the best videos clearing your
strategy clear on your Niche clear on
your marketing clear on the whole thing
clear on the market clear on Market
Research clear on the niche clear on
everything to come up with the best
strategy for moving forward if you
enjoyed this content and want to take
your YouTube channel to the next level
just click or tap the link on the screen
or go to tube 1K challenge.com to join
our next live YouTube challenge you'll
learn our best tips and strategies that
are working here at think media and I
think you'll love it